all right male birth control yeah in the
market how does it work
there was one that they came up back in
the day
and then it went through like clinical
trials and they got rid of it and uh but
what it basically did is like paralyze
the tail of the sperm so it wouldn't
swim and so you just like leave this
load of like crippled [ __ ] sperm and
your girl and then they just don't go
for the egg christopher reese sperm yes
100 percent
it's just sitting there yeah
so uh yeah but i don't know how does
this one work how does it
make you not get pregnant i don't know
there's a bunch of different ones it
seems like the pill it says like
testosterone dropped uh in such a way
that like the it's not producing viable
sperm oh that's terrible i don't want
none of that bro yeah
and then there's like a gel injection
that apparently does wonders
like [ __ ] sperm that got extra
strength yeah oh and they can swim no
matter what yeah and then apparently
there's side effects too so like some
people in the study reported like
headaches acne weight gain they also
reported some of these in placebo groups
so it's not necessarily just that and
they're basically the same side effects
as female birth control yo i did a i had
a joke about that [ __ ]
but like all these are the same side
effects that came out and then the
studies came out for them and then we
were like nah this is too dangerous
like what kind of idiot would actually
take this stuff just to not get pregnant
but damn girls were doing it man
yeah it makes more sense that they would
do it
they bear the cost yes of the practice
they're doing it to make sure they don't
get pregnant and then get [ __ ] over by
some guy yeah yeah a guy's doing it it's
a super you're a [ __ ] yeah you're a big
[ __ ] this is literally for athletes
right yeah oh it's like for athletes but
then if it [ __ ] your testosterone you
can't have it rappers you can athletes
you can't [ __ ] with your testosterone
that's the reason you're thinking oh
[ __ ] i'm not going to drop my
testosterone at any cost that's a great
point there's athletes who won't even
take like propecia so who is this for
like finance bro like back in the day
you wouldn't have done it what male
birth control yeah like early 20s when
out here just slinging nah i was
rubbering up
but instead
no no no because these girls are burning
bruh
you [ __ ] with the wrong girls though
you think yeah you could just look at a
girl on top and tell if they're burning
how do you tell you just know what do
you do
what's your favorite they look funny you
they off guaranteed 100 off yup yeah
sorry i could spot aids i can spot all
of that yes you can yeah he believes
that yes you can you didn't diagnose
yourself for 30 something years
yeah that's true do you think
you can spot everything but [ __ ] is
that it
is that part of like you know how like
people it's his rain man retardation he
can just spot you know how you get
account cards
like dogs can smell cancer and [ __ ] like
that or whatever like that do you have
like an extra super sense yeah just for
t-shirts you smell chlamydia yeah
it's kind of amazing actually yeah damn
well i'll tell you i'm nice man you were
[ __ ] nice dude not just strong hands
bro yeah you have other things you have
other abilities it seems risky for dudes
to do male birth because if a girl does
birth control it fails she still has
options
yeah i mean you could take like an
abortive pill you could do have a full
but if our ship fails
i'm keeping it whoa
whoa whoa yeah
so like there's still risk so i'm like
yeah i don't know what dude necessarily
would go for that unless maybe like
you're in a marriage and you're like all
right we can work this out yeah but the
lower testosterone is weird yeah like i
don't know if dudes want to sacrifice
that also you already get older your
testosterone starts to get lower
and that doesn't stop us from
impregnating these girls i don't know if
that's necessarily a side effect with
this specific one people are talking
about wait why would the risk be
different
because if women birth control fails
it's the same [ __ ] but they have the
power to get aborted we can tell them
how we feel
but they can't
it's like if we're choosing this versus
another birth control yeah i think
that's what mark says you're a
professional athlete you're hooking up
with some girl it's like rub her up and
you get her pregnant because your male
birth control didn't work
she's just like yeah i'm having your kid
yeah whereas if you use a condom and it
doesn't break you're like okay i'm good
oh probably good whereas if you're a
girl let's say you're some like major
finance ceo and some random dude hits it
like and you get pregnant because your
birth control as a woman didn't work you
can still get an abortion yeah
because it's ultimately you're the one
carrying the kids so you have final say
gotcha whereas with a dude you're like
yeah [ __ ] yeah i don't know man so maybe
if you're married like that would be a
good play but if you're just out here
slinging dick in the streets i feel like
you'd still wrap it up i think so you
got to wrap it up you got to worry about
the other stds yeah you know what i mean
like were you really worried about
getting girls pranked like every girl's
on birth control pretty much like i
don't know as long as you're not famous
you don't really got to worry about
getting girls pregnant i feel especially
in new york every one of these girls on
birth control
like literally everyone so did you worry
about that [ __ ] yes really i mean yeah i
don't think i would worry why would you
worry
what would make you worry about were you
having sex with girls that aren't from
new york
no actually no i wasn't really yeah it
was new york it was all new york girls
wow yeah and you were just unloading the
clippy done i got some swimmers man yeah
bro spin the whole block oh you were you
were pulling out i was pulling out yeah
for the whole nut or for a part of it i
don't know probably but he would run it
back probably
oh that's what you do and then that's
what people don't realize if you pull
out and then [ __ ] with them like one
time i did that and then did that work
i mean he got got yeah right every
single time bro
you can't do it once a night or you rub
her up yeah facts
and then you're good is it gonna be bad
for the society the dudes are like yo i
don't need a condom yes dude
dude herpes is going to go crazy yeah
like uh uh uh-uh also this is perfect
timing like you come right out of covid
like nobody's seeing each other and all
of a sudden we got male birth control
like like they haven't had this [ __ ] on
deck for a minute i think they just
realized we'll put anything in our
bodies now
yeah you know what i mean like we don't
need no clinical trials nothing just let
that [ __ ] go oh okay i don't got to
worry about getting girls pregnant bet
let's go
i won't get one that's out here [ __ ]
they want us out here partying
alcohol night life everything goes up
yeah everybody's best interest for
decide to be out there [ __ ] also how
much is it the birth control
like how much
would it cost to not get girls pregnant
i'm i'm trying i'm curious about that it
might be cross-prohibitive what do you
mean if it's 200 a month i don't think
dudes are buying it oh no i don't know
how much it is i don't even know if it's
actually released i think this is again
like another clinical trial thing uh
most likely it will be a prescription
just like female brooklyn yeah insurance
insurance companies dudes don't get
insurance though
that's also
true in the world
[Applause]
you